thank you everybody for joining us
welcome to our session on how gap
balances security and self-service in
their api program
i am vijay sairam prava i'm a product
marketing manager with apogee api
management at google cloud
and my co-speaker today is patrick
from the gap patrick would you like to
introduce yourself
hey thanks vijay appreciate the
opportunity to be here with you
to share a little bit of our api program
story with you
uh specifically as it pertains towards
the criticality of the developer portal
i'm an enterprise architect with gaap
responsible both for the
structural elements of our api platform
on apogee
both in a on-prem data center as well as
in the cloud
and for shaping our best practices with
the api program
so thanks for the chance to share with
you today
awesome thank you patrick with that
let's dive straight into agenda over the
next 20 minutes or so
we are going to look at this session in
two parts
the first part is going to cover the new
ways of shopping that are emerging and
how that is changing the priority for
retailers
and the second piece is going to focus
primarily on how
gaap is basically executing its strategy
on delivering self-service capabilities
to its developers with that said
let's have a quick look at the new ways
that the shopping behavior is changing
for consumers
in this new normal of lifestyle i think
consumers are trying new things and
forming new habits
for example more than 50 of the surveyed
shoppers that we polled
basically said that they tried new
shopping experiences for the very first
time
nearly 25 of the shoppers that we
surveyed said that they went online to
purchase something that
normally that they would always go to a
store for
and third nearly 50 percent of the
surveyed shoppers
clearly said that they would love to
have the option of curbside pickup
even after stores reopened
this tells us something about the
changing shopping behavior
obviously this is going to make
retailers to rethink their strategy
in terms of the areas of investment and
priorities in this new world normal
in the interest of time while i have
five areas that have been called out on
the slide
i will focus on two of them that i am
very passionate about
one is boosting online experience as of
today
retailers are looking at their
e-commerce investments and ramping it up
so that they're able to take on
this huge tsunami of demand that they're
seeing emerging on their digital
platforms
second they're also looking at how to
amplify
and leverage the data that they're
receiving so as to create
greater greater personalized offers for
their customers
and the third most important thing is
the retailers are now looking at the
aspect of how to repurpose some of their
existing
investments in the form of stores into
mini fulfillment locations and also
looking at how they can repurpose some
of their store associates
to become fulfillment managers the
second area where they're reimagining
customer interactions customers are now
experimenting more and more with
technologies like video
ar commerce live events etc there's a
lot more tendency of them leaning into
completely adopting a digital approach
to their retailer
the second is retailers themselves
realize the kind of high call volumes
that are being generated because of this
new normal
and are trying to adopt in areas like
customer service
leveraging the power of ai to see how
they can enable virtual agents to have
very effective conversations with their
customers
also having some of their virtual agents
being
expert assist agents for their human
agents
so all these things are happening in the
retail world from a reimagining customer
interactions perspective
and retailers are now looking at
investing more and more into
sophisticated clienting solutions
for associates shopping experience
assistant apps
for consumers so that they can have a
better shopping experience when they are
in the store
and other more fulfillment options
well all these changes are happening at
the heart of all the changes
to deliver on the above mentioned
priorities that we discussed
retailers need to focus on apis as we
know apis are nothing but
application programming interface apis
are key enablers for most of these
priorities that we spoke about
and at the de facto building blocks for
building and sharing
modern application in today's enterprise
market
and second most important piece is the
enablement of developers to leverage
these apis
in the least with the least amount of
friction so as to create
new world experiences so how do we
empower developers with apis that's
going to be the question that we're
going to try and answer
in the next couple of slides
while apis are key enabled enablers a
first step towards handling apis is to
basically have an api management
platform
you need these apis to be delivered
securely they should be managed
and analyzed across a multitude of your
environments be it on premises
cloud private cloud sas and other it end
points
to navigate this complexity and to be
able to manage your apis in a structured
fashion
as a product you need an enterprise
grade api management platform
apigee is a multi-cloud api management
platform it gives businesses
control over and visibility into apis
that connect applications and data
across the enterprise
and across clouds apigee empowers
organizations to accelerate their
business by unlocking the value of data
and delivering modern applications such
as curbside pickup
instantaneously so if you look at the
api management platform you'll see it
has four distinct areas
the first area is api gateway helps us
basically expose
services and data as consumable apis
the second layer is mediation mediation
engine enables you to basically
manipulate messages as they flow through
the api proxies
they enable you to transform messages
like from xml to json vice versa etc
the third part is what is going to be
the focus of this presentation
developer ecosystem a section of the
management platform that helps you
manage the community of app developers
that are using your apis you're
leveraging your data or your services
helps you to work for both internal and
external developers and
formalizes a relationship with financial
models and
onboards developers with creation of a
developer portal
and the last piece is analytics as the
name suggests
the more you're able to measure the
better are you able to improve your
interactions with your consumers
all the above mentioned areas play a
critical role in helping you
deliver your apis products for today's
session
as mentioned we'll look at the developer
ecosystem part
building api great products is just the
start of an api program
there is no doubt that while publishing
an api is a major milestone
but it's just the beginning of the
process the hardest part
is once you have published your apis as
products
is to attract and engage developers
who will build apps leveraging the apis
that you've created so now let's look at
what are the three main ingredients that
go into creating
an effective delivery platform it's all
about product market fit
know your customer and consumer are they
internal consumers
are they external api consumers are they
partner consumers that tells you a lot
understanding the requirements helps you
package the product
in the best way possible to enhance
product market fit
the second is bring your apis to market
it's like the codeless five piece of
marketing mix place
digital storefront is important as to
help your developers to find your apis
to interact with them to learn with them
and to actually engage with them
and the last is build a relationship
this is about creating a bi-directional
flow of
you know information where a great
developer experience starts with your
ability to be able to
onboard you know get a developers to
get fast track to their hello world api
and more importantly give them an option
to solve the problems by themselves
without having to depend on too much of
human intervention
so we spoke about what are the three
main ingredients
that are required in a developer portal
so now let's look at the overall
advantages of the developer portal and
if you look at the developer portal
there are four major advantages to the
developer portal
the first advantage is it improves
discovery
stop recreating the wheel you have the
ability of surfacing all your apis in a
structured fashion over a developer
portal
which will help the ability for people
to search
identify and consume those apis
by just improving the discovery
depending on your business case
you actually help improve your
relationship with your consumer
whether they are api consumers from the
internal part of your organization or
those external
so discovery is a very important part
second is
is is the entire aspect of streamlining
and onboarding
and self-service this is the place where
you basically help your api consumers to
securely and quickly gain access to the
tools and information that they need
to explore test and consume apis
example smart docs i'm sure you heard
about that
the third piece is learn and learn from
usage and
improve this is the part of optimizing
api programs with the power of
analytics with the power of api
performance analytics helps you gain
visibility into the api as you said
service quality
volumes are rising across pricing tiers
and more
it also gives you deeper visibility into
api performance and how
developers use them use this data to
make to understand app performance
traffic patterns issues to better make
this to make better business decisions
and the last part is security api abuse
will be the most frequent attack
vector resulting in data breaches for
enterprise web applications in 2022
that's what gartner says
you need to ensure the fact that you can
leverage the capabilities of the
developer portal
to package your api products and deliver
them with role-based permission
manage product access and security with
built-in app registration
and support for automatic and manual api
key approval
you can do all this with the help of
your developer portal
at apigee we do have a very robust
developer portal strategy
and it is a tool that will help you
build a world-class
developer experience it basically has
three main components
catalog which helps you discover enables
discovery branding theming search
content which enables learning the qa
the blog forums
the support and the analytics that you
can provide to the platform and the last
is relationship
the bi-directional relationship that we
spoke about to develop identity
app and key requests governance and api
consumer funnel
apigee developer portal comes basically
in two flavors the first one being the
integrated developer portal
and the second one being a drupal based
portal the considerations for this we
have seen across our customers primarily
hinge on two main parameters
the amount of configuration i want to do
or the amount of coding i want to do
and second is a very simple budget and
time availability
great now that we've seen the advantages
of the developer portal
we understand how apigee can help you
build a world-class developer portal
now let's try and bust this myth about a
developer portal is only for external
developers
and for partners is that really so let's
talk to patrick and find out as to how
gap is is busting this myth patrick
over to you thanks a lot vijay
appreciate the chance to share with you
what this is looking like us
at gab why we believe that integrated
development portal
is exactly the way we solve some of our
most pressing challenges for an internal
developer audience before i do that let
me share with you just a little bit
about our company
gap has been around for just over 50
years
started out in 1969 as a single store
doing blue jeans and vinyl records both
of which
jeans are still as in style as ever and
thank god vinyl records have made a
comeback
today gaap is a multi-brand global
company
but with still those same values that
have driven them for over 50 years
specific to our api program is i've
joined our team
i've watched an api program grow into
hundreds of apis
the api platform team is on boarding
both api producer and consumer teams
we'll talk more about those two personas
in just a little bit here
we are onboarding multiple teams every
single day
we've grown into over 200 developer apps
where those teams if you're a producer
team for developing and testing your
apis
if you're a consumer team for weaving
those apis into amazing customer
experiences
billions of api calls every single year
are flowing through the apigee platform
both in our own data center as well as
now in the cloud across multiple
regions
what does it look like as you go and try
to grow your api
program and your scale and complexity
increases
when i first joined the api program a
few years ago
we had two major business initiatives
one that was customer facing one which
was workforce user facing
and we had about a dozen to eighteen
core apis that both of those programs
were focused on
and relying on to meet their business
objectives
fast forward five years and those 12 to
18 core apis
is now hundreds of apis i laugh now but
at the time we started this those were
managed in a google spreadsheet trying
to keep track
on where each of those were which were
in development which were ready for
prime time
no way on earth that scales to what
we're facing today
i want to talk about this from the
perspective of two key personas
number one is the api consumer what is
the pressing question that
persona has when can i start accessing
your api
they are hounding our api producer teams
and the effigy platform team on a daily
basis
they are under tight commitments they've
got deadlines to meet they got budgets
they have to stay within
as was discussed in the introduction
here by vj covid
and the pandemic has caused teams to be
able to need to pivot
faster than ever the rules of the game
what you can do in store what you can do
online
that is changing on a daily basis and
region by region
what about the api producers
their number one pressing question is
i want to help these consumer teams meet
these business objectives
is my api ready for prime time great
i've ridden my back end of business
implementation
i have a proxy that i've wrapped that
with
but is it really ready to turn loose to
the masses yet
what we've learned over these last few
years in involving our program
is that an api goes through a life cycle
it all starts with an open api spec
apigee edit edge includes a great
open api spec 3 compliant spec editor
that becomes a point of conversation
between the team producing the api
and our infosec partners it's critical
that that be done at the early part of
the life cycle
what happens if that's delayed is a team
can be on the verge
of a production go live only to find
they have to go back
10 steps backwards when you have those
conversations up front in an agile fail
fest mentality
it's very cheap to make changes maybe
infosec says a given api needs to be
locked down a little bit tighter so it's
going to use oauth tokens instead of
keys
maybe there's manipulation that needs to
happen on a json payload
coming out of that api for a subset of
the audiences that's less privileged
those contractual details are worked out
then you start dropping lines of code
you build your apogee proxy which is
just as much a part of that api contract
as the api implementation itself it
proceeds onto infosec for pen testing
if you've got black friday haunting your
dreams at night you are load testing
those apis and eventually you are
lighting that up for the world which is
what we're doing this for in the first
place
that life cycle is a huge balancing act
the consumer teams are like the kid in
the back seat of the car on the way to
disney world are we there yet are we
there yet are we there yet
they want the lowest friction
self-service experience as
absolutely possible meanwhile as vijay
mentioned
apis are a huge attack vector
none of us like the g word but
governance is essential if you're going
to have a successful api program
you've got to make sure those eyes are
dotted and t's are crossed
and that your apis are secure both those
that are exposed on your internal
network
and any of those that may be exposed on
your external network
as we've gone through our evolution of
the program and built this life cycle
into the way apis are developed
and made ready for consumption we've
found
two major challenge areas i want to talk
about real quickly
number one is you have to have a single
source of truth
when it comes to understanding which
apis have gone through that requisite
gating
you've got to be able to go to one place
and understand what's there and for
us the perfect place to make that happen
is the developer portal
if you don't see it it's not ready for
prime time
and that may vary in that early part of
the life cycle the only people who can
see that api
should be the owning team and infosec
as it's gone through all that gating
that i described
it's now going to be lit up for any api
consumer audience
the second part has to do when a team
comes in to request access to an api
once it is ready for prime
time we have huge communication
challenges
you may have a api consumer team with 10
developers
and they're reaching out to the apigee
platform team for access to this api
that they need to meet their next
deliverable for the business
and they're going on three different
communication channels
with 10 different people effectively
asking for the same thing
but under just as many different names
it creates confusion redundant effort
and cleanup that's required these two
challenges
we believe the apogee integrated
developer portal
is really well positioned to address
but i would rather show you than tell
you so with that let me switch into a
demo
so i'd like to take some of these
concepts that we've been talking about
and show you what they look like in
practice so we've talked about apis
going through a life cycle
and progressively being opened up for
access
to a wider set of audiences so here
we've got two apis uspto
and an end of month reporting this first
one
you'll see is available to everybody
that has gone fully through the gating
cycle
it's been certified by infosec it's been
load tested
it is ready for prime time so it's
available not only to the owning team
and to infosec
but now to the consumers as well the
second
api is earlier in that life cycle and is
only available to the team that's
building that api
and then to infosec
the other concept we talked about is
how you get in to governing that kind of
access as it goes through that life
cycle
and there's a few key things you want to
see in apogee edge here
number one are developer accounts these
are users who have created accounts for
themselves
within the developer portal those users
may choose to
create teams which they will be then
made the owner of
they can add additional members to those
teams
and then there's this concept of
audiences
we've got our broad audiences of api
consumers
api producers and then our infosec pen
testing team
now right now each of these has one team
each but there could certainly be
multiple teams that are all considered
an api consumer audience
for example you also once something's
ready for full consumption by everybody
have the ability to simply say if you're
authenticated to the portal
you can see this so those are the ideas
that we have within edge
so now let's look at things from the
perspective of the developer portal
itself
right now i'm logged in with a user
that's going to simulate
being a tech lead on one of the api
producer teams
that tech lead has gone in instantiated
a team slick apis
they are an api producer team that user
is the owner of that team
but is able to delegate responsibilities
to other users who can also help in that
day in day out administration
you'll also notice that this team
currently has access to
one application suffixed with
devops which is a naming convention for
api producer teams
where the apis they access are those
would say are developing and
accessing purely for purpose of
evolution and testing
we talked about those two apis before
one that's already ready for prime time
so you see this team owns that and then
a new one
which is undergoing development
now let's come in instead as that user
that was delegated responsibility within
this team
so if that user logs in
you'll notice that they can see that
team they were made a member of
they have admin access notice none of
this is editable so they don't have
quite the same ad
access as an owner would have but they
can drill into that application
now this particular developer on this
team is actually the one responsible
for this end end-of-month reporting
application so they're going to go ahead
and add that
so that they can evolve that api its
back-end and its front-end proxy
they can leverage the api key and the
secret
whether those endpoints are governed
based on the infosec discussions by api
key or by oidc
token all of that is available for them
now let's say this user has taken this
far enough and they're now ready to have
infosec begin
pen testing on that application what
does that look like
so we're going to come in now simulating
a member of the
pen testing team
that user is going to come in they can
go to the application that they use for
pen testing
and they've been working on this other
one that's already graduated ready for
prime time
they'll go ahead and remove that if they
don't need that at the moment
but they're going to go ahead and add
this new one leveraging the same key and
secret they've been using to commence
that pen testing
so this api so far has visibility to
a infosec pen testing audience
as well as the audience of the owning
api producer team
now let's come in from the perspective
of a consumer
so we're going to come in as the owner
of the consuming
api team they're building an application
that needs this api
and you'll see there's already a team in
place for this api consumer team
this user is an owner and they've
already delegated responsibility to one
of the members of that team that's also
doing development work so that user
is there now right now there are no
applications we mentioned during the
introduction
on this talk that the covid pandemic
has really shifted the way retailers are
doing their business
and one of those is this notion of
curbside pickup
so we're going to go ahead and create an
application
for that called curbside delight
and it's going to go ahead and use that
product that's already for
prime time but they also know they're
going to need
the functionality that the end of month
reporting api
provides notice that right now that is
not visible
so i want to stop them and talk about
those two key challenges that we've
observed
these last few years number one was
single source of truth
we said if you see it it's available if
you do not see it it is not yet ready
for prime time
so notice the limited audience
for the end of month reporting api was
the owning team
and infosec but a consuming team cannot
yet see that that's a single source of
truth
all in the portal second thing we talked
about
was communication even for those apis
that are ready for prime time one of the
things that frequently happens
is multiple members of the same team
will come in and make requests some of
them by text some of them by email some
of them by servicenow tickets
all effectively for the same api
but leveraging different names for the
api they're trying to get
for the dev app they want it added to
for what team they're a part of
creates endless confusion and a lot of
redundancy
notice here this user came in could see
their team
their apps and when they did that
self-service request
it was already completely clear what
they were looking for
now in this case they can get one of the
two that they need but not the second
one
that's going to prompt them to go talk
with that api producer team and find out
what's going on
now let's assume that they have that
conversation
and infosec says you know what we just
completed our pen testing
the owning producer team in the
meanwhile has been doing their load
testing that is now certified
this api is ready to be graduated so
previously it was visible only to the
owning team in infosec
we are now going to make this api
visible to everybody
we're doing that through consumers you
could also choose to move away from
audiences and just say
any authenticated user depending on your
requirements and your configuration
we're simply going to add consumers to
this mix
now if i come back in
as the member of that team
that's consuming this that needs
end-of-month api access
they can drill right into the
application
and notice they now have visibility to
this
that app has graduated all gating and is
now ready for broad consumption
self-service and they've got themselves
access to this
so you've seen a few key concepts we've
demonstrated this idea that you can have
this
experience which is self-service low
friction
simplifies communication leverages the
portal as a single source of truth
all while not having to sacrifice
governance that's key to a secure
api program hopefully this gave you an
idea
you might do this a little bit
differently in your organization
but hopefully it gives you a sense of
what a developer portal workflow might
look like
for an internal developer audience like
we have
i hope if you've gotten anything out of
the talk here
it's a handful of key concepts number
one if you want an api program
that's focused on innovation and agility
you
have to have a low friction experience
without that it becomes frustrating for
everyone involved
but that low friction self-service
experience cannot come at the sacrifice
of security
api governance does have to be there
we believe that a developer portal gives
me a way
to achieve both of those to find that
balance between the two
they don't have to be at odds with one
another there's a way to have both
and we think the apogee integrated
developer portal is exactly
the right way to accomplish this for
gaap
there's a lot of developer options i
would be the first to tell you
your organization may be better suited
for the drupal portal
another organization like ours we
believe the integrated developer portal
is the better fit
you guys pick the one that fits your
needs the best
great thank you patrick that was amazing
i loved i loved i loved the example of
the sheets oh my god imagine managing
all those apis
through a spreadsheet but you know what
i think gaap has come a long way
and i'm really envious about the kind of
progress that you folks have made
and are continuing to make so i think
the takeaways were great
but i have one question for you if you
were to change
one thing about how you did things what
would it be
and why if i could go back
five years and do anything different
it would be to make sure that from day
one
out of the gate we had that developer
portal in place
we're in process of moving from opdk to
hybrid
as we do that that opens up the door for
using the integrated developer portal
the way i've demoed it here
unblocks us on all these major
challenges but if i could go back we
would have had that portal live from day
one we would have built those process
flows with that low fiction but good
governance balance already in place and
we would have built that collective
muscle memory around what those
workflows look like
leveraging the portal so that that's not
something you transition into later
it's your starting reality from day one
awesome thank you patrick uh you know
this has been great uh thanks a lot for
taking the time to join us
uh i would like thank to thank everybody
who's joined us for the session i hope
you had some nice
key takeaways one major takeaway for me
is
don't let a developer portal be an
afterthought and show the fact that it's
a part of your thought process
as you're putting together your api led
digital strategy
with that said thank you and have a
great day